long time L a sports writer does a
weekly NBA column for the LA news group
mark Heisler back on the program mark
thank you for joining us if I told you a
month ago this would be the Lakers
roster what would you what would you've
said what problems would you have had
with that nobody you know having tracked
LeBron you know I mean along with
everybody else you know we've been
tracking lie brought every step of the
way you know from Cleveland to LA you
know starting months and months and
months ago or a year ago you know when
we found out he had two homes out here
and was obviously you know obviously had
the Lakers on his list it was you know
because it was a relatively short list
of teams with capital the supposition
all along was that LeBron would dot-com
unless another guy you know of his
caliber came with them you know
everybody was looking at Paul George and
you know so and that one all the way up
until you know the first night of free
agency when magic and LeBron met for
like three hours
and obviously magic sold him on coming
by himself Paul George was already off
the board had gone back to OKC at that
point Chris Paul was about to re-sign
with Houston and you know what the
Lakers did was they pushed that they
pushed the other half of the plan back a
year and they're now looking at next
year to bring in that big guy in LeBron
you know at the age of 33
LeBron sat still for you know which was
you know major surprise all along and
then of course came all these personnel
moves the Lakers started making you know
none of whom anybody would have
predicted you know Lance Stephenson my
god yeah nobody would have predicted
they'd pick him up on waivers so you
know javale mcgee rajon rondo
and so you know so here here we are next
year's Lakers but you know the one thing
you have to bear in mind about them
they're highly transitional and it feels
like so everybody's sort of a
one-and-done situation here almost like
that bridge roster to get them to what
LeBron is really going to want next
season is that a fair assessment yeah
and I think you know I think at this
point because you know for the first
time in a long time LeBron has committed
long
term you know he's on a four-year deal
he's not you know this isn't the usual
you know one-on-one deal that he signs
it makes him a free agent a year so now
it's getting you know it's going to be a
joint venture it's going to be as much
about what magic once you know
supposedly these guys that they picked
up our magic skies and not LeBrons guys
oh these were these were guys that you
know they were imagine because magic has
this you know there's just thought about
Cleveland you thought that they were too
specialized you know and especially
tilted toward shooters Kyle Korver JR
Smith you know I don't particularly see
it that way
but he didn't want that he didn't want a
Cavaliers type team he wanted a team
where everybody could switch on on
pick-and-rolls and they could you know
guard that way and you know put more
teeth in their defense and so that's why
they picked these guys up but they're
all on one-year deals all these guys
I've mentioned and so you know they're
very obviously keeping their options
open for next year and you know the
options are you know they can create a
Mac slot for anybody and you know it's
not just Kawhi Leonard you know who's
likely to be on the market next year you
know it's also Kevin Durant and Anthony
Davis so at this point you know I'd say
there's a good at you know is you know a
better chance of Kawhi Leonard never
being here and somebody else being here
instead but I also look at what the
Lakers I guess what magic is trying to
build and I've said all along everybody
thinks they can play like Golden State
does you know LeBron thought that he
could have an East Coast version of
Golden State we know that you know they
they didn't have that nobody has that
roster are we going to see teams that go
in the opposite direction that that I
know basketball cyclical that do we go
back to where somebody's going to have
something that counteracts Golden State
where a Golden State actually has to
account for somebody else's roster
instead of the other way around you know
I don't think so or if if it happens
it's going to be a long way down the
road people are just starting to go you
know Golden State I mean you know that
there's a lot of teams obviously that
have but you know it's it's an
incomplete process you know it's
interesting you see this guy DeAndre
you know the number one overall pick and
he's in summer league right now and the
first summer league game he was playing
against Alice's team and they started
double-teaming him hard in the post so
you know you can't play in the post the
way you used to because nobody will let
you they will double team faster they'll
make you you know use other options so I
do think the spread court model is is
going to you know people are going to go
to it as you say you know it's going to
be you know nobody's going to do it as
well as Golden State is because the
Oldman state has basically done it you
know as well as it's ever been done and
in my mind they did a dutter before they
got Kevin Durant of course you know now
they know they have an extra great
player so okay so maybe they're not
quite as efficient but no I think I
think you know the new game is here to
stay and you know people will get more
and more committed to it and we'll play
smaller and smaller you know mark I was
watching NBA highlights the other day
and it was Lakers Celtics NBA Finals and
and the way the game was played on both
ends like it was all compacted they're
like it it can't you it's so startling
to watch it because you're going nobody
was spreading the floor even though you
had good outside shooters back then it
was all compacted back then in the mid
80s yeah absolutely you know that I mean
the the Laker game plan you know used to
be you know absolutely fall back on the
lane and make Danny Ainge and Dennis
Johnson proved they could make shots now
neither of those guys were great
shooters you know like in the middle of
their career but you know when one
challenge they got to be a lot better
shooters you know it was interesting
because in the 80s because the cell you
know it because I thought this before
and I've watched that you know and when
you see see highlights
you know the game was really nice and
fluid back then and you know despite the
fact that the defense is concentrated on
the lane it was still a really cool game
to watch and then after that it slowed
down and you know post basketball you
know really came in and it was you know
throw the ball in the post in the
shaquille and Hakeem and wait for the
defense the double-team and you know and
then eight seconds later you would throw
the ball out and he would reverse it and
it was really awful and it got slower
and slower
or you know until basically Mike
D'Antoni in Phoenix around 2005
well I blame Pat Riley and Mike fratello
didn't they sort of bring about
greco-roman wrestling there with with
basketball and Chuck Daly and all those
guys young and even Phil Jackson you
know because you know for you know the
Bulls played pretty slow in the Triangle
did you
is there any like Luke Luke Waltons job
is safe for this year is that fair to
say Oh easily they're very they're very
committed to it and the other thing is
you know not getting the extra guy is
going to keep expectations relatively
humble for a LeBron team which of course
you know they're never humble people are
gonna understand that they're you know
they're working really for two years
down the lane
so the Lakers if fans don't Lakers
certainly do Lucas Lucas is absolutely
safe for you know for this year next in
an amazing that Luke Walton came in in
the same draft with LeBron D Wade to
Phil Jackson could be involved with the
Lakers as a coach and coach no
absolutely not
you know they've gone on beyond him you
know I mean first of all you know you
have that you know you have the personal
relationship between you know Phil and
Jeannie you know which you know they may
you know which they're no longer you
know engaged and but the Lakers Lakers
have made the decision you know when
they hired what when they hired Luke you
know they wanted the Golden State
offense you know which in their minds is
the Showtime off yes
you know updated and so you know and
that's you know Jerry Buss was a big
thing for you know visioned
style of play flashy entertaining
appealing to Hollywood so you know
that's really in their DNA do you think
LeBron and win another title you know
that would be a hard bet you know say a
33 year old guy coming to a team you
know that's not a championship contender
is gonna win another title but I'd say
maybe I'll give him 50% chance I just I
still look at Kevin Durant
as you know like the x-factor here if if
all of a sudden he wins another title or
two titles and then all of a sudden says
you know let me do something different
here let me head down the coast here now
did you see what are the possibilities
of Kevin Durant as a Laker you know I'm
you know I'm not I'm not you know I
don't know all that much about what's
cause it was on you know with Kevin
Durant but I think you know it's pretty
interesting to me you know that LeBron
texted him about coming to the Lakers
and the next thing you know Durant is
signing a deal that makes him a free
agent in a year is so yeah I mean you
know and you know the other great free
agent next year is gonna be Anthony
Davis you know who's gonna be you know I
just looked it up I mean Kevin is Durant
is 29 who I just turned 27 Anthony Davis
is 25 and fits you know with the new
basketball so you know I think I would
think you know the Lakers are going to I
think leg is gonna have pretty nice
selection
what about it Kawhi Leonard do you just
wait that out with San Antonio or if
you're San Antonio do you say we're
gonna lose him let's just get as much as
we can from the Lakers because that's
his only destination well I think you
know I thought how long the trading of
the Lakers would be the last thing that
they want to do and you know so you know
apparently you know they're asking for
two number ones and two you know swaps
of number one picks I don't I don't
expect them to trade on the Lakers I
expect them to wait as long as they can
to get the best deal they can on you
know the fortune of the difficult thing
for San Antonio is that you know the
price is just dropping because wise
telling everybody he just wants to be a
Laker
Mangia balls future in LA secure you
have to be determined you know he's
gonna have to play a lot better than he
did last year he's gonna have to make a
lot of outside shots you know there's
gonna be a lot of finger pointing at him
because you know they're now at the
point you know they put up with
everything from his father because they
thought he was the hope of the franchise
you know back before they got Lebon you
know they you know he was the only one
who could who really had breakout
potential you know you know admirers
thought they saw Jason Kidd there well
you know we don't know that that's not
true but it is certainly didn't have
last year so but you know now that's not
the case anymore LeBron is going to have
the ball and if you know
Lonzo better be hitting at least 35 36
percent of those threes you know that
that he gets how about making a free
throw mark like that that stood out even
more how do you have a guy who has the
ball who can't make free throws I'm a
longtime NBA writer so you know we kind
of like numb out on who's the worst
free-throw shooter you ever saw
oh let's see I think Kim Hughes what his
numbers were he was pretty bad he was
like 40 41 percent I think yeah and then
you know and then you know of course you
know even if you know Shaq's just
performed nothing at least he would
always say this but he would always say
to me I I could make them in practice
and I go but the amazing thing is I saw
it happen in practice I saw him knock in
like 20 when you see that you know you
you realize how much of it is a head
game but then there's no video of that
like will it's 100-point game there's no
video of I heard it for years and didn't
believe in that I saw all right now mark
thank you I appreciate your time right
place right there that's a mark Heisler
does an NBA column for the LA news group
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]